félicitations puis bienvenue chez nous
ludovicque réy peut avoir le sourire il
vient de signer un CDI chez adeco il ne
travaillera pas à l'agence comme les
autres salariés mais pour elle puisqu'il
s'agit d'un CDI intérimaire il
continuera donc à avoir des missions
dans différentes entreprises mais il est
à présent assuré d'avoir un salaire
entre deux périodes de travail une
stabilité rassurante pour lui qui a
toujours été en intérim un nouveau
statut qui va lui faciliter la vie
ouais c'est pour trouver un logement
pour des demandes de prêt pour plein de
choses comme ça les choses courantes de
la vie quoi Francis jant lui a déjà été
en CDI reconnu travailleur handicapé il
fait de l'intérim depuis qu'il est
arrivé dans la région il y a 4 mois et
pour lui aussi ce CDI intérimaire est
une véritable auben d'autant qu'entre
deux missions il aura la possibilité
tout en étant payer d'effectuer des
formations et il a déjà un plan de
carrière où est-ce que j'étais avant
j'étais chef d'équipe enfin j'ai fini
chef d'équipe et donc si je pouvais
retrouver une formation pour devenir
chef d'équipe ou même plus haut il y a
aucun problème je suis je suis pour adco
leader du travail intérimaire en France
ces nouveaux contrats sont une petite
révolution ça nous a permis de changer
l'image du Travail Temporaire nous
sommes des agences d'emploi
effectivement qui mettons à disposition
dans les sociétés des intérimaires sur
des plus ou moins courte durée et
l'objectif effectivement c'était de
pouvoir fidéliser nos intérimaires à
vitam et ternam en leur proposant un CDI
intérimaire si le CDI intérimaire est un
engagement contractuel entre le salarié
et adco il inclut également une
entreprise sous forme d'engagement moral
pour ces deux contrats adeco a choisi
satateba une entreprise richelaise avec
qui l'agence travaille depuis 20 ans et
qui n'y voyait que des avantages ça va
donc changer donc d'avoir des salariés
qui vont être plus investis probablement
dans leur travail et plus décontracté
aussi dans leur travail avec moins les
contraintes du stress de la vie d'être
intérimaire et de pas savoir ce qu'ils
vont faire comme travail le lendemain
les de nouveaux cdisés qui avaient déjà
fait des missions d'intérim à satba
travailleront donc pour entreprise
durant les six prochains mois